an der grenze zur ukraine stehen
zwischen 100 tausend russische soldaten
der westen ist besorgt und setzt auf die
kraft der diplomatie heute nachmittag
haben us präsident biden und der
russische präsident putin das gespräch
gesucht um den konflikt zu entschärfen
putin drohen harte sanktionen das hat
auch die eu heute angekündigt aber wie
schafft man ein stabiles verhältnis zu
russland und wie verhält sich die neue
bundesregierung wenn der ernstfall droht
krisengipfel putin beiden kriegsgefahr
in der ukraine unser thema in der
phoenix runde
einen schönen guten abend herzlich
willkommen aus berlin darf in meine
gäste vorstellen bei uns ist agnieszka
broker frisch gewählte stellvertretende
fraktionsvorsitzende von bündnis 90 die
grünen mit dem schwerpunkt
sicherheitspolitik schon guten abend und
herzlich willkommen alexandra einer der
führenden russland experten lange jahre
war engagiert für den petersburger
dialog projektleiter des deutsch
russischen forums und er berät den
russischen konzern gazprom und
zugeschaltet ist uns johannes farwick er
ist professor für internationale
beziehungen und europäische politik an
der martin-luther-universität
halle-wittenberg und er hat mit anderen
deutschen sicherheitsexperten einen
aufruf gestartet für einen neuanfang im
verhältnis zu russland
und herzlich willkommen andreas kluth
kolumnist bei blumenberg pinien früher
handelsblatt global und die economist
ist us-amerikaner mit sitz in berlin
schönen guten abend haben wir beide
seiten also hier auch vertreten herr a
wenn wir uns das anschauen knapp zwei
stunden oder gut zwei stunden haben
beiden und putin miteinander gesprochen
die tatsache dass sie miteinander in
einem video gipfel wie wir ja alle im
moment per video miteinander reden in
einem video gibt viel miteinander reden
ist das schon ein erfolg an sich ich
denke ja zwei stunden sind genug zeit um
über wichtige dinge zu reden und wir
wissen ja noch nicht viel was aus diesem
gibt für herausgekommen ist aber die
tatsache dass zum beispiel bei der
gemeinsamen gesundheitspolitik
gesprochen ist über globale
sicherheitsfragen auch über die ukraine
natürlich wurde auch hart gesprochenes
über sanktionen gegenüber russland aber
auch putin hat sicherlich seine
forderung durchgebracht die ukraine
wieder zu einem neutralen staat zu
machen ist nicht in die nato aufzunehmen
es ist eine ganze palette von von von
dingen auf dem tisch gewesen und ich
denke die anfangs atmosphäre war auch
kollegial weiter haben sich eigentlich
begrüßt es war keine feindlichkeit zu
spüren für beiden und für putin geht es
denke ich könnte mich natürlich ehren
aber in erster linie diesen konflikt um
die ukraine zu entschärfen zu
deeskalieren damit es nicht zu diesen
zusammenprall zwischen russland und den
usa oder russland und westen kommt frau
broker wie haben sie es empfunden die
tatsache dass gesprochen wurde und
siehst ja das aus amerika aus den usa
aus der richtung ganz klar gesagt wurde
hier wir haben harte sanktionen vorfalls
ist eben ein militärisches eingreifen
gibt konnte konnten die usa sozusagen
ihren punkt da machen also wie gesagt es
ist noch nicht so wirklich klar was
genau wie besprochen worden ist aber
dass erst mal gesprochen wurde ist
natürlich ein ganz wichtiges zeichen
eine ganz wichtige botschaft gerade wenn
man diese gefahr abwenden will die ja
auch ganz unmittelbar da ist dann muss
man miteinander ins gespräch gehen weil
natürlich eine solche situation einfach
sehr anfällig ist für missverständnisse
für eskalationsspirale und es muss jetzt
darum gehen auch in solidarität mit den
menschen in der ukraine dafür zu sorgen
dass die situation sich entschärft dass
die bedrohung geringer wird und dazu
gehören natürlich auch klare ansagen die
deutlich machen wo eine grenze ist
besonders gut fand ich aber auch dass
präsident biden sich ja auch mit den
europäischen partnern vorher verständigt
hat das war ja heute auch teil der
berichterstattung und das ist also nicht
nur als us amerikanischer präsident
gesprochen hat sondern auch gemeinsam
die botschaft und den schulterschluss
mit der europäischen union gesucht hat
herr farbig wie haben sie es empfunden
dass gesprochen wurde und vielleicht
auch gleich noch wie bedrohlich ist denn
im moment die lage in der ukraine
also ich glaube sprechen ist natürlich
gut das wird niemand bestreiten aber es
kommt schon darauf an was man bespricht
und ich glaube die interessenslagen
liegen relativ klar auf dem tisch und
wir haben eine sehr bedrohliche lage und
wir sollten wirklich alles tun um raus
aus dieser eskalationsspirale zu kommen
und ich halte nichts von roten linien
aber ich halte viel davon dass wir
interessen ausgleichen und mit einem
nüchternen realpolitischen blick an
diesen fragen gehen und realpolitischer
blick heißt dass wir weder
beschwichtigung machen noch eskalieren
sondern einfach mal versuchen die
russische sichtweise zu verstehen weil
was russland jetzt macht mit diesem
aufmarsch an der grenze ist ein klares
stopp signal zu senden und wir sollten
das nicht viele interpretieren sondern
sollten uns wirklich mal die mühe machen
die russische position nachzuvollziehen
ohne auf alle interessen eingehen zu
können natürlich aber russland hat noch
nicht seinen platz in der europäischen
sicherheitsarchitektur gefunden und wir
sollten daran arbeiten dass das anders
wird und dann muss man auch im westen
ein paar dinge anders dh sie würden
sagen russland die 100.000 soldaten
stehen zu recht an der ukrainischen
grenze
nein die stehen nicht so recht da und
mir geht nicht darum mir geht es nicht
darum was ich sympathisch finde oder in
einer idealen welt gut fände aber es ist
doch ganz offenkundig dass russland eine
ausweitung der nato an seinem
territorium als bedrohung seiner vita
ein sicherheitsinteressen versteht seit
1990 sind 14 staaten der nato
beigetreten
wenn die ukraine das auch täte werfen
russland gewissermaßen die berühmte rote
linie überschritten und gleichzeitig
wird für russland die rote linie
überschritten wenn dauerhafte
nato-truppen in der ukraine stationiert
würden das ist nicht so schwer zu
verstehen und wir sollten das verstehen
und ich glaube das ist nicht nötig dass
das passiert ich bin dafür dass wir die
ukraine gewissermaßen finnland visieren
also einen neutralen status vereinbaren
das geht nur mit der ukraine nicht über
die köpfe der ukraine sondern dafür
brauchen wir eine neue hochrangige
konferenz an der alle beteiligten an
einem tisch sitzen und in dieser zeit
sollten wir ein moratorium nachdenken
also ein fries bei der erweiterung der
nato das würde glaube ich in dieser lage
schon viel helfen das werden die
interessen russlands herr kloth helfen
sie uns mit den interessen der
amerikaner welche interessen haben die
amerikaner die ukraine so zu
unterstützen die ja nicht nato mitglied
ist also wenig überraschend sehe ich
etwas anders die situation wenn ich
zusammenfassen würde natürlich reden das
besser als nicht reden aber wir sind in
asymmetrischen situationen der westen
nicht nur die usa der westen hat nicht
eskaliert in diesem konkreten fall hat
wladimir putin eskaliert und wir wollen
auf jeden fall
deeskalieren und nur der eskalieren und
wir wollen dinge auch mit sanktionen
wenn es dann so weit kommt wie immer
wieder boten eine möglichkeit geben roth
vor seinem baum runter zu klettern auf
der anderen seite putin muss sich immer
überlegen ob er deeskalieren will europa
eskalieren will abhängig sagt man es
gesprächen dominanz ich weiß nicht ob
das auf deutsch sgs eskalierung des
dominanz er hat einen strategischen
vorteil der durch weil er den ton und
die geschwindigkeit und die nächsten
schritte angibt wir der westen die die
unterhalten sich anscheinend jetzt
gerade putin und draghi und auch noch
merken und micron so weiter müssen sich
halt überlegen wie reagieren auf was
damit es nicht so weit kommt aber
letztendlich wissen wir die entscheidung
wird putin treffen frau war sehen sie es
auch so ist es so dass putin da der
dominante spieler ist in dieser
auseinandersetzung und sozusagen
bestimmt wie der westen dann reagieren
kann und soll also ich sehe schon auch
dass die eskalation
gerade in den letzten monaten deutlich
von russischer seite ausgegangen ist im
gegenteil in den letzten monaten gab es
ja auch immer wieder gesprächsangebote
jüngere zum beispiel an den besuch von
herrn borel in moskau wo man nicht das
gefühl hatte dass der dialog jetzt an
der europäischen union gescheitert ist
und die fragen die häufig angesprochen
hat die stellen sich ja gerade
unmittelbar nicht und deshalb ist die
sorge groß wohin das alles führen
sondern deshalb hat sich schon auch für
richtig klar zu machen wenn es hier zu
weiteren regelverletzungen kommt wenn
die territoriale integrität der ukraine
nicht nur gefährdet ist sondern wirklich
auch verletzt wird dann muss es auch
konsequenzen geben ich glaube man muss
schon eine sehr klare sprache in so
einer gefährlichen situation sprechen
und gleichzeitig immer wieder klar
machen dass unser interesse gute und
gemeinsame beziehungen und kooperation
sind der altbundeskanzler wenn er morgen
dann gewählt wird olaf scholz hat heute
auch noch mal gesagt die
unverletzbarkeit der grenzen ist sehr
wichtig und hat auch noch mal die
besorgt dass die besorgnis ausgedrückt
herra wie weit sehen sie das also
welchen schritt könnte russland denn tun
damit diese eskalationsspirale nicht
weiter angeheizt wird also wir tauschen
informationen aus meinungen deshalb
widerspreche ich auch einigen die
aussagen die hier gemacht worden sich
aber nicht den von herrn farbig weil er
natürlich einen punkt hat auch in dieser
sendung ist es doch interessant zu
wissen und festzustellen was die
russische intention eigentlich ist und
da gebe ich zwei beispiele ich bin
ständig in russland und versuche auch
objektiv mit menschen dort und vor allen
dingen in der führung zu reden und
gerade jetzt gibt es eine große
diskussion darüber in russland ob wir es
nicht mit einer zweiten kuba krise zu
tun haben und das beispiel ist nicht
schlecht sie werden das verneinen aber
auf der anderen seite bringe ich das
beispiel mit absicht weil von 60 jahren
im jahre 62 damals chruschtschow diese
wahnsinnstat vollbracht hat und raketen
in kuba stationiert hat die in der lage
waren innerhalb von zwei minuten
washington new york zu treffen was hat
präsident kennedy gemacht er hat gesagt
ich riskiert den dritten weltkrieg aber
diese raketen werden abgezogen der cruze
hat das gemacht daraufhin ist die lage
eskaliert und dieselbe situation haben
wir bloß jetzt spiegelverkehrt in der
ukraine so wird das gesehen und so sehe
ich das auch das natürlich ist die
möglichkeit gibt dass die nato mit der
zeit nicht jetzt wenn die ukraine immer
näher an die nato kommt dort militär
leistung aufstellt die die russen als
gefahr für sich sehen dann können sie
aber genau und anders gesehen dadurch
dass die russen da stehen natürlich man
das ist ja die ukraine waren also muss
die nato also dadurch treibt putin der
ukraine näher an die nato das ist die
eskalationsstufen gehör aber wir
versuchen das hier zu entwirren aber die
frage war ja was kann russland tun um zu
deeskalieren russland will für sich die
garantie haben dass die ukraine nicht in
die nato aufgenommen wird sondern
neutralen status bekommt so wie das vor
dem majdan vor 2014 von den revolutionen
und man da noch festgelegt war von
janukowitsch war und den anderen
präsidenten der ukraine man habe kräuter
sind 14 hat er hat russland haben die
krim besetzt ich rede davor war die
ukraine ein neutraler staat um was es
geht ist auch um eine tat die
saakaschwili damals vollführt hat als
der südossetien angegriffen hat um
schnell in die nato zu kommen es gab
dann russisch georgischen krieg der das
unterbunden hat dieselbe situation für
russland ist die nato-erweiterung nicht
akzeptabel dass hat putin 2007 auf der
münchner sicherheitskonferenz klar
gesagt und wir können beim wort nehmen
wir können das alles abnehmen aber da
sind die russischen interessen über die
mich fragen was ist das ich
wollte antworten dass die logik von dem
reis eine erpressung blick also putin
will natürlich das am liebsten hätte
eine garantie dass die ukraine niemals
der nato-beitritt übrigens davon redet
im moment wie freiburger gesagt hat
niemand also ein nato beitritt war
überhaupt nicht auf der
tagesordnung
diese garantie und jetzt eher skaliert
er und droht waffengewalt an
um und würde auch noch mal das meer
budapester memorandum von 1994 noch mal
verletzen nachdem es schon seit 2014
immer wieder verletzt hat um
letztendlich joe biden zu erpressen und
was soll joe biden und was sollte die
nato den machen eine ohne die ukraine
eine aussage sagen dass die ukraine
beitreten darf damit werden seine
einflusssphäre bekommt die ukraine ist
immer noch ein souveräner staat und wird
das auch noch selber entscheiden müssen
und noch mal im moment hat niemand über
ein nato beitritt geredet deswegen ist
das amerikaner folgt wenn es wird auch
ein monat version mit der blattlinie
puten den westen vorführen will
wahrscheinlich auch die neue deutsche
regierung testen will und joe biden
erpressen will wir finden sie es vor
wurde ist aus einer erpressung wurden
sie auch so weit gehen ja ich glaube
schon dass es eine erpressung ist auch
ehrlich gesagt mit blick auf die
grenzsituation polen belarus wo es
natürlich einerseits um den diktator
lukaschenko geht aber man weiß vermutet
wahrscheinlich ja nicht ganz zu unrecht
dass auch wladimir putin dort nicht ganz
unbeteiligt ist und das ist ja das
problematische an der eskalationsspirale
die debatte über waffenlieferungen an
die ukraine die gewinnt jetzt wieder an
fahrt in den usa das war auch teil des
pakets das ja präsident beiden heute
wieder in den raum gestellt hat sollte
es zu einem angriff kommen und das ist
ja genau eigentlich nicht im russischen
interesse deshalb darf man dem nicht
nachgeben und deshalb kann einer solchen
bei einer solchen eskalationsspirale
eigentlich niemand gewinnen auch die
russische führung nicht und deshalb ist
es so wichtig dass man gemeinsam zu den
regeln zurückkehrt die man miteinander
in europa vereinbart hat dass man mit
ein anderer spricht und dass man diese
eskalation jetzt stoppt also das darf
man aber nicht nachgeben weil wenn eine
solche strategie erfolg hat dann wird
sie immer wieder und immer weiter
angewendet aber welches interesse hätte
die nato jedoch mal eine hat mit ihrer
helfer machen sie zuerst der farbig wie
hat nicht einmal einen haken darf also
natürlich heiße ich ganz bestimmt nicht
dass die russischen erpressungen jetzt
gut das ist gar keine frage
aber gleichzeitig müssen wir doch sehen
dass gewissermaßen der zug in richtung
nato in der ukraine doch auf dem gleis
ist und das wollen die russen verhindern
und ich glaube das ist ein legitimes
interesse und natürlich geht das nicht
über die köpfe der ukraine entdeckt dass
wir dieses legitime interesse
gewissermaßen den russen zu belegen aber
wir müssen die entwicklungen der
vergangenen monate und jahre sehen ich
will nur zwei beispiele nennen die
ukraine haben die nato mitgliedschaft
als verfassungsrang in ihre verfassung
aufgenommen ganz gewiss nicht ohne
zustimmung der amerikaner zweites
beispiel wir hatten anfangs september
ein gipfel zwischen sellin ski selensky
und beiden im weißen haus wo ein neuer
amerikanischen klinischer
sicherheitspakt gegründet wurde wo
deutlich das ziel der annäherung an die
nato festgeschrieben ist wo
waffenlieferungen festgeschrieben worden
sind das heißt in russischer perspektive
ist das auf dem gleis und es will jetzt
sozusagen ein stopp zeichen senden ein
stopp signal senden und das müssen wir
ernst nehmen aber ist es nicht der
politik heißt eben immer mit den
außenpolitik wenn ich das noch sagen
darf heißt eben immer mit den augen der
anderen sehen und natürlich haben wir
keine aggressive absichten und wir sagen
unsere militärhaushalt ist 67 mal so
groß wie der russische wenn man den
westlichen zusammen nimmt und wir haben
keine aggressive absichten das stimmt
aber in der russischen tradition ist es
eben eine verletzung der vitalen
russischen interessen wenn die nato
gewissermaßen russland ein kreis und
dabei ist die maus keinen faden ab das
aber hatte russische pässe aber hat denn
ihr einfach clou aber ist die koalition
einzugehen da aber ist er hat es nicht
dies nicht begonnen 2014 mit der
besetzung der krim hat also wer hat denn
da was zuerst verletzt wäre doch eine
berechtigte frage da derart völlig
richtig wir werden muss sozusagen
verurteilt werden gar keine frage aber
auch da wenn wir die krim frage als
sozusagen voraussetzung für
diplomatische gespräche sehen dann
werden die nie stattfinden die krim ist
russisch ob uns das gefällt oder nicht
mir gefällt es persönlich überhaupt
nicht aber wir sollten diese creme frage
nicht immer wie eine monstranz in allen
fragen vor uns hertragen sondern wir
müssen von den realitäten in der
internationalen politik ausgeben
ausgehen weil die alltags wenn die reben
eine eskalation ohne ende ist und das
ist mein punkt wir müssen raus aus der
eskalationsspirale und vielleicht
sollten wir auch nicht über sanktionen
mit blick auf russland reden wenn ich
das noch sagen darf sondern auch über
ökonomische anreiz zu reden wir müssen
russland einen platz in der europäischen
sicherheitsarchitektur einräumen so
schwer dass heute sein
wenn man so mit russland verstehen in
deutschland zusammensetzt dann hört man
viele dieses wort der der russischen
konzeption wladimir putin hat uns ja
einen gefallen getan diesen aufsatz im
juli glaube ich oder im sommer zu
schreiben dann haben wir bestimmt alle
gelesen längerer aufsatz die wir seine
sicht der geschichte und der ukraine und
belarus muss dann aus seiner sicht hat
er da ja geschrieben ist die ukraine gar
kein richtiges land hat gar keine echte
identität und belarus auch nicht sondern
die drei also russland belarus ukraine
sind sozusagen ein großer russischer
raum das klingt für mich da gehe ich
nicht in die in die minister crisis und
geschäft da gehe ich noch etwas weiter
zurück das macht uns angst das sollte
uns angst machen er sieht die ukraine
nicht als land mit grenzen und und
verletzt diese grenzen immer wieder und
durch diese bedrohungen sind wir in die
situation gekommen dass die ukraine sich
jetzt natürlich irgendwie schützen will
und dadurch dadurch hat die ukraine
interesse irgendwann mal der nahe zu
treten aber wenn wir über perzeption
entsprechender sollten wir erstmal über
das bild über von wladimir putin
sprechen dass er sich macht mit
einflusssphären und groß russischen
räumen stadtstaaten mit grenzen die die
respektiert werden trotz der klub noch
mal die nachfrage welche interessen
haben die amerikaner denn daran die
ukraine so zu unterstützen
naja die die das interesse der
amerikaner ist weitere russische
übergriffe und angriffe und aktionen und
invasionen zu verhindern
das ist ich glaube das ist
selbstverständlich mittleren osten
frauenbundes soll jetzt erinnern mich
heute nicht was ich habe das alles macht
der welt man das ja schönrederei es
kommt während sie haben ihre kenntnis
muss sind jetzt dann mischen wir die
debatten ist über die ukraine näher vor
sehen wir übrigens war alles versuchen
wir mal auch mit dem blick auf eine neue
bundesregierung die am morgen ihre
arbeit beginnt frau bogon der olaf
scholz hat heute gesagt auch bezug nimmt
auf diesen sc von putin ohne ihn zu
erwähnen hat er gesagt hat es gehört zu
dieser diskussion gehört die
unverletzlichkeit und unverletzbarkeit
der grenz das ist ganz ganz wichtig dass
niemand in die geschichtsbücher und wels
um grenzen neu ziehen zu können das war
glaube ich richtung putin gemünzt frau
broker wie schafft man das denn jetzt
wie was nehmen sie sich vor als der sie
haben ja auch die koalitionsverhandlung
mitgeführt beim thema sicherheitspolitik
um zu sagen wie sollte sich jetzt
bundesregierung neu aufstellen in der
außenpolitik in bezug auf russland ich
finde dieses wortpaar was die zukünftige
außenministerin berbalk immer wieder
auch an führt von dialog und das erste
wort ist dialog und aber einerseits
härte genau richtig wir haben sehr
intensiv auch mit der spd und der fdp
über die russland passage im
koalitionsvertrag
gesprochen und da ist zum beispiel auch
die anerkennung ja dass russland ein
wichtiger internationaler akteur ist da
ist die botschaft auf der basis der
gemeinsamen vereinbarung auf der basis
des internationalen rechts wollen wir
auch kooperieren aber es ist auch eine
sehr klare sprache die das benennt was
wir auch sehen innenpolitisch und
russland am umgang mit der opposition an
menschenrechtsverletzungen aber auch die
aussenpolitische aggressivität und was
glaube ich wirklich auch eine neue
sprache in diesem koalitionsvertrag ist
und ich halte das für sehr richtig ist
dass die perspektive unserer
osteuropäischen und mitteleuropäischen
nachbarn und freunde dort auch eine
rolle spielt bei der gestaltung der
beziehungen mit russland das gehört
nämlich auch an dieser stelle mit dazu
und zugleich ist aber auch klar wir
haben da jetzt keine feindbilder ja dass
die visafreiheit für bestimmte
zielgruppen gerade für junge menschen
bis 25 mit drin ist zeigt doch dass wir
eigentlich wollen dass die beziehung
zwischen den menschen auch unserer
beider staaten weiter ausgebaut werden
wir hatten eine bewegende debatte ja
auch mit angestoßen durch die grün
historisch noch einmal zurückzuschauen
auf den überfall auf die sowjetunion der
sich letztes jahr vor 80 jahren gelehrt
hat also es gibt viele anknüpfungspunkte
wo man einen guten dialog führen kann wo
man auch zusammenarbeit und kooperation
machen kann aber eben auf der basis der
regeln die wir gemeinsam miteinander
vereinbaren kann vereinbart haben und 94
budapester umrandung ist schon erwähnt
worden damals hat man die
territoriale souveränität der ukraine
zugesichert russland als ein staat der
mit dafür sozusagen die garantie gegeben
hat für die abgabe und vernichtung der
ukrainischen atomwaffen und solche
regelbrüche einfach hinzunehmen und als
realpolitik anzuerkennen und zu sagen
und jetzt tun wir einfach so als sei das
nicht geschehen und machen einfach
weiter setzt doch die botschaft in die
welt dass man die regeln immer wieder
brechen kann keine konsequenzen
befürchten muss und dass man mit militär
politik steigt aber die frage wie das
funktioniert mit zum einen dialog und
auf der anderen seite aber dann auch
härte und klare kante was erwarten sie
denn von der neuen bundesregierung in
richtung russland also dass sie dem land
neue bundesregierung stark bleibt ihren
prinzipien treu bleibt natürlich
menschenrechtspolitik aber auch
interessensausgleich man kann sich auf
der anderen seite nicht gleich mit allen
anliegen mit den russen chinesen türken
und iraner sondern das wird
fingerspitzengefühl in eine sehr starke
orientierte nach realität suchende
außenpolitik
darauf müssen wir setzen aber ich habe
angst dass die bundesregierung hier über
den tisch gezogen ich erinnere an das
jahr 1999 sage ich gleich 1990 war eine
frische unerfahrene außenpolitische
regierungen der macht schröder und
fischer die amerikaner und die engländer
haben
diese bundesregierung in dem krieg in
jugoslawien gedrängt und wir haben
mitgemacht
wollen nicht alle das machen wollten und
heute auch mit die situation der ukraine
ich will das nicht sofort sogleich
vergleichen aber der druck auf die
bundesregierung auf die neue jetzt eine
härtere position gegenüber russland in
jeder hinsicht anzunehmen jetzt heißt
das dass die engländer amerikaner die
geheimdienstler irgendwelche
informationen den deutschen ministern
oder bundesregierung liefern die zeigen
sollen dass die russen wirklich morgen
angreifen aber ich hoffe nicht dass das
fake news sind wie beim irakkrieg oder
woanders also trauen sie annalena
baerbock als neue außenministerin die
natürlich noch unerfahrener diesem abend
ist trauen sie ihr dass dieses am zu und
zum beispiel ihren russischen kollegen
lawrow auf darin klare kante zu zeigen
es geht nicht nur eine klare kante das
wäre falsch wenn sie mit dieser
intention nach russland werden kann das
den medien ihre zählt die sie dafür
feiern werden wichtig ist ins gespräch
zu kommen
trauen sie ihr das zu dass sie das
schafft sie wird schon die richtigen
berater haben und eine deutsche
außenminister muss in dieser rolle
wachsen die hat kaum zeit sie muss das
machen natürlich und sie wird
hoffentlich auch in verbindung mit stolz
mit dem bundeskanzleramt die richtige
linie finden die werte die vertritt
jetzt nicht nur die grünen-partei und
menschenrechtsorganisation sondern
deutschland und auch die europäische
union deutschland das europäische
führungsmacht und natürlich muss man
sich mit den polen natürlich muss man
sich mit den balken absprechen aber
genauso mit den franzosen mit italienern
und in spanien die auch eine andere
politik gegenüber russland wollen also
europäischer konsens ist richtig aber
nicht einseitig auf osteuropa
hingewiesen es heißt deutschland will
eine dienende führung in dieser
führungsrolle in dieser außenpolitik die
soll aber auch werten basiert sein das
hat man heute auch noch mal gehört
herwig was erwarten sie da von der
bundesregierung sehr mir diesen aufruf
gestartet dass sie einen neuanfang
wollen in den beziehungen zu russland
was trauen sie annalena baerbock zu
also zunächst mal würde ich sagen der
alte satz von strategen gehe von seinen
beständen aus und nicht von deinen
parolen den sollten wir beachten und was
sind die bestände ich sehe niemanden der
wegen der ukraine in den krieg ziehen
möchte in den usa nicht und auch in
europa nicht und das ist auch gut so das
heißt es bleiben noch
wirtschaftssanktionen da haben wir
gelernt in den vergangenen jahren dass
die nicht wirksam sind weil wenn es um
vitale interessen geht dann sitzt man
das aus und kann das aussitzen und
russland hatte in diesen fragen vitale
interessen das heißt
wirtschaftssanktionen würden nur zu
einer verhärtung der russischen position
führen das heißt wir haben keine
alternative zur diplomatie und
interessensausgleich und ich habe in der
tat auch so ein bisschen die sorge in
der werbung auch schon außenpolitik dass
menschenrechte demokratie
rechtsstaatlichkeit gewissermaßen in
einer idealistischen überhöhung vor sich
her getragen werden ohne auf die
interessen zu gucken und ich glaube das
wäre ein fehler wir sollten wieder
anknüpfen an die alten gedanken einer
modernisierungspartnerschaft mit
russland das ist alles nicht sehr
populär gerade ich weiß das und ich weiß
auch dass man sich schnell den vorwurf
eine russland verstehe er als ein
handelt aber ich bin gewiss keiner ich
bin ein sozusagen im nato contact
sozialisierter wissenschaftler ich bin
voll der überzeugung dass wir
abschreckung brauchen und da militärisch
handlungsfähig sein müssen und ich bin
auch der meinung das ist ein unterschied
macht ob man nato mitglied ist oder
nicht nato mitglied ist das heißt dass
die sicherheit der balken unsere
sicherheit ist die sicherheit der polen
usw das ist völlig unbestritten aber die
ukraine ist eben ein anderer fall und
deswegen sollten wir auch anders über
die ukraine reden es gibt keine
alternative zu der eskalation in diesen
fragen wie gesagt eben dass wir der
ukraine an anderen player an der
sicherheitsarchitektur einräumen als
polen oder gar sie sagen sanktionen
nicht militärisches vorgehen sowieso
nicht oder ich glaube er lud will da
glaube ich heuer gehen und dann frau
probiert
ja gerne ich gar nicht reagieren ist hat
jetzt alle so geklungen von herrn farr
weg des miteinanders dass sie
vorschlagen dass wir eben dass der
westen gar nichts machen sollte wenn er
sich die ukraine ganz eingeschnappt oder
zu drei vierteln malta antritt der
westen sollte das aber wohl nicht
möglich sein denn auch wenn die
sanktionen vielleicht nicht ihn aus der
ukraine wenn er sie mal hat wieder
zurück bringen würden
würden sanktionen und wir können ja mal
vielleicht durch die mögliche die die
liste durchgehen was da so alles ansteht
was möglich ist die können den preis für
putin der ukraine schon sehr hoch
treiben was wäre denn was wäre denn was
wäre denn eine sanktion die wirklich
funktionieren würde also ein beispiel
das jetzt für die neue deutsche
regierung würde ich auch gern hören was
frau kosor sagte frau war eigentlich auf
der richtigen linie ist natürlich dass
diese neue sagt man pipeline auf
deutschland sogar
zwischen russland und deutschland auf
gar keinen fall in betrieb genommen
werden soll obwohl sie fertig ist denn
es war schon immer und habe das jetzt
alles abstreiten schon immer klar allen
ländern in europa und nordamerika außer
deutschland ist es klar dass das ein
geopolitisches strategisch projekt von
booten und gazprom ist um erstens durch
das schwarze meer durch die extreme und
zweitens die doppelte linie durch das
baltische das baltische meer um zentral
und osteuropa nicht nur die ukraine
vielleicht auch die anderen länder
umgehen zu können und um die dann
eventuell erpressen zu können und das
ist allen mittlerweile klar und darum
hat frau merkel jetzt in den letzten
monaten sehr hart daran gearbeitet
besondere rangers mit auch der ukraine
und russland zu machen dass das noch
nicht passiert aber dass das beste
druckmittel das wir eben haben ist diese
gaspipeline jetzt erst mal leer zu
lassen frau programm will die neue
bundesregierung und auch mit namen die
außenministerin würde sie sich dafür
einsetzen dass gazprom eben nicht ans
netz geht da hat der koalitionsvertrag
ja und da eigentlich schon sogar schon
das sondierungs papier eine formulierung
gefunden die besagt dass eben das
deutsche und europäische recht in diesem
bereich eingehalten werden muss das
verfahren hat jetzt begonnen bei der
bundesnetzagentur danach wird die
prüfung durch die europäische kommission
folgen und es hat ja schon ordentlich
geholt hat also das lief es nicht
wirklich reibungslos weil auch bestimmt
regel nicht erfüllt worden sind aber ich
glaube trotzdem dass es jetzt nicht
darum geht möglichst wild über
sanktionen zu spekulieren natürlich gibt
es im finanz und wirtschaftsbereich
durchaus noch spielraum aber unser aller
ziel ist doch jetzt zu einer
deeskalation zu kommen und da gab es
jetzt eine sehr einige europäische
haltung die klar gemacht hat ein
militärischer übergriff ein angriff
würde nicht ohne konsequenzen bleiben
aber in der tat wir wollen das nicht
aber was wäre dann also die konsequenz
gazprom wer keine die sie betreffen
würden also dass die pipeline nicht ans
netz gehen zu lassen also wir haben als
grüne ja in der vergangenheit immer
wieder so eine sehr klare haltung auch
zu dieser pipeline gehabt sowohl aus
klimapolitischen erwägungen aber auch
oft um mit blick auf die
sicherheitsinteressen mit blick auf die
fragen reagieren ja jetzt mit spd fdp
und alleine der regierung genau im
koalitionsvertrag vereinbart dass wir
auch jetzt erst mal dieses verfahren
abwarten dass wir diese prüfung abwarten
und das von unserer seite aus sehr klar
ist dass diese regeln eingehalten werden
müssen herr sie beraten dass ein berater
gasproben aber sicher wir können uns
natürlich jetzt darüber ewig streiten
ich finde einfach meine philosophie es
dass wir eigentlich eher die
zusammenarbeit suchen müssen im sinne
vielleicht der brandts ostpolitik oder
das was die deutschen immer wieder
gemacht haben was frau merkel auch getan
hat sie sagt diese pipeline macht uns
nicht abhängig von russland sondern sie
macht auch russland abhängig von uns wie
die anderen pipelines auch in dem auch
deutsche firmen in russland gutes
geschäft machen und wir erdgas aus
russland bekommen es gibt nicht so viele
bezugsquellen es gibt noch norwegen die
amerikaner liefern kann flüssiggas nach
europa aus afrika kriegen wir das erst
recht nicht und außerdem außerdem kann
diese pipeline auch das hat man in
russland natürlich auch ganz offiziell
gesagt vielleicht auch mal genutzt
werden um wasserstoff nach deutschland
zu bringen sie ist modern genug um das
zu machen und über die ukraine wird
weiterhin gas fließen über polen und
weißrussland fließt ich würde diese
pipeline jetzt in ruhe lassen weil sie
wird dann nur noch böses blut bringen
dann werden sich die russen wieder
angegriffen fühlen und werden dann
ihrerseits gegen deutschland trifft
irgendwelche neuen sanktionen verhängen
wie die das schon mal gemacht haben ich
finde das 1 1 am brenner was wäre denn
ein guter erster schritt oder was wäre
dann etwas was pushen bewegen könnte
seine truppen abzuziehen dem die nato
natürlich auch ihre truppen abzieht aus
dem schwarzen meer wo dort auch eine
eskalation beginnt indem man das macht
was her farbig richtig gesagt hat in
seinem aufruf lang übrigens scheiben
jetzt deutschen grill ein zweiter aufruf
also in deutschland wert ist da melden
sich mehr und mehr leute zu wort die
einen dialog wollen auch den
petersburger dialog wiederbeleben wollen
es geht darum dass wir mit den russen
wieder ins gespräch kommen weil es geht
um eine gemeinsame sicherheit es ist
richtig dass die ukraine selbst über
ihre
mitgliedschaft verfügen müssen das ist
ein souveräner staat natürlich ist das
so aber wir dürfen doch das ganze bild
nicht vergessen die russen fühlen sich
als größter flächenstaat in europa und
als atommacht ausgegrenzt aus der
europäischen sicherheitsarchitektur und
übrigens ja sie haben das budapester
umrandung gebrochen hier aber
gleichzeitig haben wir auch die pariser
charta gebrochen wo drin stand dass wir
einen gemeinsamen sicherheits- und
gemeinsamen kulturraum einen gemeinsamen
wirtschaftsraum gründen werden zusammen
mit den russen das hat man den
versprochen werden viel mehr machen
müssen um das zu erreichen anstatt nur
die nato bis an die russischen grenzen
zur dazu zu zu erweitern und ich hoffe
dass olaf scholz als vielleicht einer
der enkel von brand und
und uns schmidt vielleicht das eine oder
andere was aus politik angeht hier
wieder beleben möchte obwohl das ich
weiß es nicht populär der clou das war
auch was das schaut aus den usa auch in
richtung auf deutschland auf eine neue
bundesregierung hat man da gewisse
erwartungen dass man sagt also wir
hatten ja in den vermerk in england
konnte gut mit putin kommunizieren
einfach auch weil beide einander putin
spricht deutsch frau merkel spricht
russisch das ist jetzt alles anders die
frage ist auch was schaut man auf die
somit mit was schaut mal aus den usa auf
die neue deutsche bundesregierung
aus den usa und aus brüssel schaut
natürlich jetzt sehr intensiv auf die
bundesregierung aus verschiedener
hinsicht erstens will man wissen auch
wieder wäre interessant fast frau bürger
dazu sagen will
hat die bundesrepublik vor jemals das
nato ziel von zwei prozent ungefähr dass
des bips auszugeben für die bundeswehr
in europa würde man bestimmt gern wissen
wie es mit der fiskal integration weiter
gehen soll viele fragen ich wollte aber
noch ein anderes thema ansprechen das
hier total verloren gegangen ist
beziehungsweise ob das jetzt die
situation als ob putin nichts getan hat
jetzt der westen würde die sich so
freuen wenn putin sagt ja ich will
wieder einen dialog bitte modernisieren
wir zusammen harmonisch dann würden wie
alle türen würden auffliegen und das gas
wieder fließen und so weiter aber was
ist passiert seit vielen jahren stellen
die ununterbrochen findet die hybride
kriegsführung stadt durch desinformation
durch attentate durch sogar diese
zynischen dinge die natürlich
abgesprochen sind zwischen lukaschenko
und putin dass sie kinder und frauen und
männer also flüchtlinge an die grenzen
fliegen und in richtung polen an zäune
treiben im winter
eins nach dem anderen und das ist ja zu
der hintergrund dieser dinge diese
ständigen versuche er in interviews in
unseren wahlen in den usa sowieso in
unseren demokratien er will unsere
systeme steht stabilisieren und in
diesem kontext zu sagen wir müssen doch
einfach wieder zum dialog zurückgekehrt
dann müsste man muss erst mal seine
verhaltensweise korrigieren was will er
dann soll er erklären will er uns
stabilisieren dann muss er zuerst damit
aufhören und dann können wir anfangen zu
reden und das würden wir sehr
enthusiastisch angehen hamburger zuerst
und dann hier verbirgt welche der lust
auf die ganzen fragen einzusteigen sie
würden unser originäres thema verlassen
vielleicht gewöhnt dass ich einmal
anderen rahmen noch mal fortsetzen ich
will auch ein ganz klar sagen weil wir
jetzt immer wieder in die geschichte
zurück geschaut habe ich würde auch
sagen dass der westen oder die nato auch
fehler gemacht hat also das nato
raketenabwehrsystem weil zum beispiel
wirklich etwas von dem immer klar war
soviel mehr sicherheit wird uns das
nicht geben es gab von russischer seite
zu nahe anderen zeit ja das war noch vor
der reaktion der krim
durchaus ein interesse daran gemeinsam
zu kooperieren die nato hat es relativ
eiskalt abgelehnt und da eben die sorgen
die von russischer seite geäußert worden
sind jetzt berechtigt oder unberechtigt
nicht ernst genommen dass obama gesagt
hat russland ist eine regionalmacht ja
auch etwas was uns ganz sicherlich nicht
mehr sicherheit gebracht hat sondern
ganz viele gesprächskanäle zugemacht
trotzdem rechtfertigt das alles nicht
was in den letzten jahren passiert ist
und da sollte man auch nicht naiv drauf
schauen und das ist auch das was
annalena baerbock ja auch immer wieder
klar macht mit dem dialog und und der
härte dass wir auch unsere gesellschaft
resilient machen müssen dass sie sich
schützen müssen vor diese information
vor spaltung es versuchen ich glaube
dass ein kalkül dieses truppenaufmarsch
es durchaus auch sein kann mal zu testen
wie wir eigentlich zusammen stehen ja
und wie die neue bundesregierung sich an
der stelle auch verhält und deshalb
finde ich diese klarheit die es dort
gibt sehr sehr richtig und der dialog
ist nicht an uns gescheitert aber es gab
ein hacker angriff auf unser parlament
es gab ein mord im tiergarten vor den
toren des bundestages die
außenpolitische aggression in syrien in
der ukraine das ist alles kann man jetzt
angeschlagen auf werner mal die ganze
menge sachen habe ich wie sehr also da
wenn man all das auf zählt wenn man
sieht was also welche aggression ist
dann von russischer seite gibt sie sagen
trotzdem muss russland versteht man muss
aus den augen russlands das sehen wie
kriegen sie das zusammen
also alles schreckliche dinge die ich
überhaupt nicht verharmlosen möchte nur
wenn man das als vorbedingung für
verhandlungen macht dann landet man am
ende bei einer vorstellung dass man eine
art regime wechsel in russland braucht
bevor man wieder mit russland redet und
das ist eine absurde vorstellung dass
heißt wir müssen mit dem russland reden
wie es im moment ist und muss nun
natürlich versuchen es zu verändern aber
den aufruf den sie jetzt erwähnt haben
den haben ja eine ganze reihe an leuten
unterzeichnet die überhaupt nicht in dem
lager der russland versteher sind da ist
der ehemalige general naumann der
ehemalige generalinspekteur der
bundeswehr da sind einige ehemalige nato
botschafter deutsche nato-botschafter
experten die nato kontext arbeiten all
die sagen wir sind in einer so
gefährlichen
keiner wirklich brandgefährlichen lage
wo wirklich krieg in europa droht dass
wir ohne vorbedingungen jetzt eine
internationale hochrangige konferenz
initiieren müssen und da kann
deutschland eine rolle spielen natürlich
muss deutschland das mit seinen partnern
abstimmen aber deutschland kann ein
anwalt für eine solche konferenz sein wo
eben ohne vorbedingungen diese
eskalierende situation in der
europäischen sicherheitsarchitektur
besprochen wird dazu gehört auch die
dimension über die wir noch nicht
gesprochen haben die völlig aus dem
ruder laufen rüstungskontrolle thematik
wir haben die basis verträge für
rüstungskontrolle in europa den bach
runtergehen lassen von emf bis kse bis
offener himmel und noch viele andere
mehr dh sie haben eine wirklich
brenzlige situation und all das schreit
danach dass man wieder miteinander redet
und zwar ohne vorbedingungen und in
dieser zeit wo man miteinander redet
diese frage der nato-erweiterung
einfriert das wäre glaube ich der
schlüssel dafür und dann braucht man
auch nicht aber das wäre ja dann wenn er
wenn man aber wenn man sagt die nato
sollten diese soll sozusagen das
einfrieren dann könnte man doch aber
auch sagen dafür müsste auch putin
irgend ein zugeständnis machen
das denke ich ist ein teil des pakets
natürlich aber wir müssen raus aus
dieser eskalationsspirale und wenn nur
noch die situation bleibt dass man
gewissermaßen sanktionen verschärft oder
fassungslos jetzt vor dieser eskalation
steht dann hat diplomatie versagt und
diplomatie muss das ist die kernaufgabe
von diplomatie muss win win situation
schaffen und diplomatie hat auch die
aufgabe viele schmutzige hände zu
schütteln idealismus und diplomatie
passt nicht zusammen das heißt wir
müssen von den realitäten ausgehen ja
jetzt aus dieser lage wieder rauskommen
weil die alternative ist wirklich eine
eskalationsspirale die für uns alle
brandgefährlich sie sehen sofort ran
herr eine kurze frage nach idealismus
und diplomatie passt nicht zusammen
frauen broker weiß annalena baerbock das
annalena baerbock weiße gut ja wie eine
politik auf basis des internationalen
rechts aussieht und deshalb ist eine
politik der werte auch immer eine
politik der stärke weil noch mal wenn
wir das einfach alles so hinnehmen und
sagen wir tun da jetzt nichts wir
nochmal niemand hat etwas gegen dialog
niemand hat dagegen etwas zu sprechen
ich wäre auch absolut dafür dass der
nato-russland-rat wieder tagt aber ich
hätte schon auch die frage an herwig wo
aus seiner sicht in den letzten jahren
eine eskalation von seiten der
europäischen union oder der europäischen
staaten ausgegangen ist im gegenteil ich
habe gesehen trotz der wiederholten
regelbrüche gab es immer wieder den
versuch gesprächs formate zu schaffen
klar zu machen bei den sack zu und wir
werden herzlich bereit die
zurückzunehmen wenn auch diese
regelbrüche sozusagen der vergangenheit
angehören und das alles ist nicht
passiert und ich kann nicht erkennen wo
jetzt von seiten der europäischen union
oder der nato in den letzten jahren die
eskalation ausgegangen ist ja ich würde
trotzdem
grundproblem was mir her sind hierbei
vor bürger gefallen hat ist dass sie
auch gesagt hat die nato oder wir müssen
auch unsere fehler zugeben natürlich
müssen die russen auch ihre fehler
zugeben da stimme ich ihnen bei das wäre
beginn eines dialogs aber einen dialog
kann nicht und ich habe manchmal das
gefühl dass wir einen dialog mit den
russen so machen wollen dass am ende wir
wieder siegen unsere argumente die
richtigen sind und die russen sich
schämen müssen wir das was sie machen
ich kann nur sagen wenn sie denn ich war
des öfteren einen solchen
veranstaltungen wie war bei club und so
wo man den putin und anderen russischen
experten auch zu wort kommen lässt und
dort wird immer wieder gesagt wir machen
um selbst vorschläge an die deutschen an
die europäer und die werden nicht gehört
zum beispiel ein stabilitätsfonds
wiederaufbau syriens gemeinsamer zum
beispiel befriedung afghanistans jetzt
wo die flüchtlingskrise aus afghanistan
zu uns mit uns uns europa und russland
gemeinsam bedroht gemeinsame kampf gegen
den terrorismus wir reden ja zwischen
den geheimdiensten gar nicht mehr
darüber warum kann die europäische union
nicht mit eurasischen wirtschaftsunion
endlich eine partnerschaft eingehen es
geht ja in nicht russland sondern
kasachstan
zentralasien um armenien auch in
weißrussland wo man die sachen
vielleicht doch in einem dialog
charakter besser klären kann also der
ball lief tatsächlich in beiden jahren
nicht anderen einfluss auf lukaschenko
zum beispiel neben den russischen den
welle russischen macht haben um ehrlich
zu sein ich glaube ja hat einfluss auf
lukaschenka aber der einfluss putins
wird auch weit überschätzt auf
lukaschenkos schenker ist ein einzel
player
ein
choleriker der auch russland in vieler
hinsicht reizt und ich sage ihnen auch
eins voraus wenn er sieht dass der
westen wieder mit dem reden will dann
wird er wieder russland den rücken zu
kehren um zu sagen ich will nicht teil
russlands zu werden ich will meine
doppel rolle spielen eine 2 weg der
politik zwischen west und ost wie groß
ist die gefahr eines wer eines krieges
vom broker wie schätzen sie das ein
blick wird das gesehene in der politik
das ist die große frage die
wahrscheinlich am ende des tages nur
vladimir putin beantworten kann was sein
wahres kalkül ist ich hoffe dass es
nicht wirklich der plan ist eine weitere
militäroffensive zu starten die uns
wirklich dazu führt dass nicht nur
unfassbar viel leid passieren wird das
wieder internationales recht gebrochen
wird und noch mal es geht da nicht um
westliche werte sondern das budapester
memorandum die un charta die schlussakte
von helsinki das sind ja dokumente die
russland auch alles mitgetragen das war
ja gute fortschritte in der außenpolitik
seit ganz kurzem noch ein clou der
farbig wie groß schätzen sie die gefahr
einer wirklich militärischen eskalation
an die begehung groß wird die von usa
aus gesehen
rechten moment wir haben krieg
also die kämpferische behandlungen gibt
es ja eigentlich ständig eben in der
östlichen ukraine wir reden jetzt über
eine eine invasion und sagen ein krieg
der ukraine aber sie fragen was ist die
gefahr zwischen eines krieges zwischen
dem westen genau der estland und das
wieder rein rutschen
das macht mir auch in gesprächen mit
pinker sind sie weit öfter sorgen ist
man es gab viele zwischenfälle wo
russische kampfjets ohne transponders
die das baltikum rauf und runter gerast
sind und so nah an dänische flugzeuge
angekommen also da kann einiges
passieren aber ich glaube nicht also
werden sozusagen ich bin mir sicher dass
der westen nicht für die ukraine in den
krieg ziehen den krieg militärisch okay
dann sag nur noch einen satz der weg war
am ende der sendung sind
also zunächst einmal wir haben 14
tausend tote in der ukraine das heißt es
gibt krieg in europa aber dass der
westen für die ukraine in den krieg
zieht halte ich auch für
unwahrscheinlich aber das
eskalationspotenzial dieser krise ist
enorm und es steht sehr viel auf dem
spiel und deswegen ist jetzt sozusagen
ein neuer anlauf nötig um diese gefahr
zu minimieren und den neuen anlauf gab
es heute in dem in dem video gipfel
zwischen präsident putin und präsident
beiden sind gespannt wie das weitergeht
vielen dank für ihr interesse vielen
dank hierfür die diskussion und morgen
wird olaf scholz dann zum bundeskanzler
gewählt die neue regierung nimmt ihre
arbeit auf und darüber sprechen wir dann
natürlich auch am abend in der phoenix
runde bis dahin tschüss
[Musik]